asked the defendant Trayvon Newsom in
this case the defendant is guilty of
murder in the first degree as charged in
the indictment
almost five years after XXX tentacion's
fatal shooting I am
[Music]
three men were found guilty of
first-degree murder in connection with
his death as seen in court footage from
law and crime Network count one
we the jury find us follows us to the
defendant Diedrich Williams in this case
the defendant is guilty of murder in the
first degree as charged in the
indictment
count two we the jury find as follows us
to the defendant Diedrich Williams in
this case the defendant is guilty of
armed robbery as charged in the
indictment in July of 2018
xxxtentacion whose real name is just say
onfroy was inside his car when he was
shot multiple times as he was being
robbed the jury who deliberated for a
week leading up to Monday's verdict
heard prosecutors claimed that the
rapper's murder was premeditated we the
jury find us follows us to the defendant
Michael Boatright in this case
the defendant is guilty of murdering the
first degree as charged in the
indictment three individuals Michael
Boatwright Dietrich Williams and Trayvon
Newsom are expected to receive life
sentences at the time of his murder
xxxtentacion was 20 years old
foreign